So, the question is, can you please explain what happens in transforms.to tensor step?
So, the idea is that in the PyTorch library, we work only with tensors, while in normal
Python, when you load an image, it loads as a PIL image, and you print it out, you'll
see that it's a NumPy matrix, right?
So, what we want to do is, we want to convert that NumPy matrix or NumPy array to a tensor
before we can actually allow PyTorch or the PyTorch model to work with it.
So transforms of two tensor converts whatever input you have provided to a tensor, right?
So, we do not apply horizontal flip in the validation set because that is an extra augmentation,
right?
So, in the validation set, you just want to test how your model is performing on the
images that you have provided, right?
You do not want to change that image and then ask to test the model, rather you want to
test the image as is.
So, that is why we are not applying horizontal flip because if you apply horizontal flip,
you might actually disrupt the model and you might actually get artificial gains in performance.
So, rather you want to look at how the model is performing on the image that you have provided.
That is why we do not apply any further augmentation apart from converting to tensors, normalizing
and resizing.
The question is, how will we know how many units in the penultimate layer of a model?
If we want to fine tune smoother model also with PyTorch, can we only pretend models built
using PyTorch or models created using other library like Keras can also be trained.
So, let me get to the first part of the question.
So, basically it is subject to experimentation and that is really kind of hyper parameter,
the number of units that you want to unfreeze or layers that you want to unfreeze.
So, again as I told you, so it is a kind of hyper parameter that you need to tune with
your validation data.
And also it depends on, so if you think about, if you have many layers to be unfrozen, so
that will require bit more compute power than if you freeze or unfreeze very small number
of units, right.
So, I think that depends on your compute budget as well.
So, if you want to fine tune smoother model, some other model.
Okay, so if you are talking about the number of units in the penultimate layer, so that
is there in your pre-tent model, so you know the backboard network, so for example, if
you have this resonant in your, to be your pre-tent network, so that is quite fixed that
how many units that you have in the penultimate layer, I think that answers your question.
Yeah, so again you can print the architecture size and in every layer you get to know the
size of the layer.
So, finally, as we, as also with PyTorch, can we only pre-tent models built with PyTorch
or models created using other library like Keras can also be trained.
So, actually whenever we pre-tent a model and we are basically interested in the parameters
and their values after pre-tenting and that is what is important for us, so as long as
that is available to us, it really does not matter whether that has been trained using
one library or the other library.
Want to add anything?
So just one other point is that, so in PyTorch and Keras, these have certain, when you save
the models, so as I said, if you are saving only the, if you are saving only the parameter
values, then it's fine, but if you are saving the entire model including the architecture
and just want to load it up, then that becomes PyTorch or Keras or whatever library dependent
and then there is, there are some other plug and play libraries that allow you to actually
take a PyTorch model, convert it into an intermediate representation and then take that representation,
convert to any other library, for example Keras.
So I believe one of them is ONX, ONX, so you can check that out as well.
Can we extract scientific property values using NLP from research articles, if yes, how?
So there are many answers to these questions and it depends on what kind of pre-tent model
that you are going to use to solve this problem, right?
So let's say you want to use a very baseline architectures like B or T, so there you can
create a data set where you have the scientific property, scientific articles, research articles
and from that you know what are the scientific properties, right?
Basically if you think about what kind of information that you want to extract, for example
you want to extract the names of the molecules and their property, something like that.
So then you have to create a kind of small training data set and find in the BERT model
using that data set, right?
So this is one way of doing that.
But nowadays as you know there are large language models, so there you can solve this problem
using prompt engineering technique, where you can write a prompt explaining how given
a research article you can extract scientific properties, then with say one shot or zero
shot learning you can come up with a system which can tell you given a research articles,
what are the properties and their values.
When training this model, so the next question is when training these models are there any
rules as to how many images or examples of each class do we need to provide to get an
accurate model, right?
So there are no rules as such.
The idea is that the more data you have the better it is, but the thing is that if you
have very small amount of images by very small, it can have many different meanings depending
on the data set or the domain.
Now for example in image data sets you would ideally want as many images as possible.
So for example in your case if you have limited amount of data, let's say maybe 10 or 20 images
per class, then what you want to do is you want to use these pre-trained models for your
particular benefit.
But for example if you have large number of images, like let's say 10,000, 20,000 images
per class, then that's a good starting point and you can actually maybe use a pre-trained
model or you can actually train a model from scratch.
But again there is a kind of another view.
So in many cases you know some of the classes, the examples of that class may be very abundant,
but for some other classes the examples are very rare.
So in that case you have a kind of skew in the distribution of the examples across the
classes.
So there as this is happening naturally you have to take care of that by introducing some
other techniques to deal with this.
So imbalance distribution of the examples in the classes is also a kind of scenario and
there are several techniques to deal with that.
Next question please, are the special token name standard is CLS 1, will the token name
be same even we are training different pre-trained language model or are they model specific?
So I think this is a kind of standard token name that is being used and more or less all
the pre-trained language models they make use of these kind of special token, but again
there are variations.
Thank you.